[Music]
so we meet again
let's go through the top picks of new
games coming in August 2019
that want your hard-earned cash so work
a little overtime mow a few extra lawns
or beg the leader of your household for
videogame money I realize we're not all
made of money so I've managed to find a
free game to tide you over during the
summer and a budget 1/2 so hopefully
something for everyone
August is a month with a little horror a
handful of action a sprinkle of RPGs and
the occasional apocalypse like usual let
me know what you'd like me to upload
some gameplay off and I shall do so
here's 7 games worth your time
throughout August 2019 the flagship game
of the month is control an
action-adventure title from remedy
entertainment the people that brought
you Max Payne and quantum break and
speaking of quantum break we never got
that on ps4 so this will be the first
time many gamers see the brilliance of
that Northlight engine oh it looks
gorgeous the story is based around the
FBC
the Federal Bureau of Control attempting
to seek out phenomena which violates the
laws of reality cool premise isn't it as
you can see this is a third-person game
with unique mechanics some would call
them supernatural a little telekinesis a
touch of levitation and destruction and
to link this back to the title Jesse can
get into the mind and control some of
her enemies we are told there are many
loadouts to this game prompting
different playstyles
which should help in replayability and
as this is a remedy game expect a strong
storyline keeping everything nicely
together but expect someone to be
kidnapped because for some reason
someone's always kidnapped in a remedy
game control releases on ps4 Xbox one
and the PC on August 27th
[Music]
the next game has a ridiculously long
title the dark pictures man often a damn
let me help getting that title into
context this is a game series named the
dark pictures and this the first game in
that series is called the man of madam
good to clear things up isn't it as you
can see the man of Madonn is a suspense
game horror filled classic if you played
until dawn on the ps4 you know exactly
what to expect here we will control the
main characters and attempt to guide
them from a ghost ship yeah that's gonna
be plant wedding least scary so I'd
appreciate if you didn't pick this one
because I don't want to play it please
because you don't want to see a grown
man screaming like a five-year-old the
brilliance of the man of madam apart
from the atmosphere of course is the
multiple permutations to the plot and
story characters can die at any point or
maybe they'll choose different scenarios
to play through this comes back to the
greatest thing in video gaming
replayability if I do play it I'll
likely kill everyone in my first
playthrough deliberately how about you
and the dark pictures the man of madam
releases on August 30th on ps4 Xbox and
the PC 2 let's focus on something a
little less frightening please this is
rec fest if you're a gamer from the good
old days you'll fondly remember the ps1
classic Destruction Derby whacking your
vehicle into someone else's is strangely
addictive rec fest brings that
destruction into 2019 with smooth racing
mechanics which are impacted by every
shunt and hit on the road too much
damage in one area can see your steering
effected acceleration stunted and
ultimately too many hits and you'll be
wrecked with over 40 vehicles and 20
tracks to choose from breakfast should
keep racing fans happy but if you don't
want a race and you here for the carnage
take it to the destruction ring the
campaign in single-player mode has us
earning money to upgrade our vehicles
this can be to simply toughen up your
heap of junk or improve its stats for
better performance in harder races rec
fest released earlier this year on PC
with a Metacritic score of 81 out of 100
so it's pretty damn good this could
definitely be worth your time breakfast
hits consoles on August 27th and when I
say consoles I mean the ps4 and the Xbox
one
here's a game which releases on July
30th yes I know that's not August at
them this video is a lie this is the
blackout Club which I missed last month
but wanted to give it some attention
have you kept telling on this game if
not I'll quickly give you a rundown in
the town of red acre things are
happening to the adults and something is
hiding under the streets every time you
wake up for some reason you're covered
in cuts and bruises and mud you black
out at night and sleepwalk it's time for
you and your teenage friends to find out
what is really happening when you black
out let's cut to the chase here there's
a boogeyman an evil angel who will hunt
you down and this is where the cool
mechanic comes in you can only see him
when your eyes are closed how terrifying
does that sound our job is to
investigate the area with other players
and record the events in the world but
don't get caught every single night a
different adventure starts the blackout
club releases on ps4 Xbox and over on
Steam on July 30th ok it's a summer
people are off school people need a game
to play that's free so let's throw one
in now I'm hugely intrigued by this game
but the title is pretty terrible
it's called Caravan stories ok before
you click on to another video take a
look for a second is pretty good Caravan
stories is an RPG choosing a character
class like an elf an archive good old
boring human and is even a lizard man
coming soon in future updates the usual
RPG formula is in place here battles and
exploration award skill points which are
attributed to your character grind
through these adventures and build your
perfect Caravan there's over 100 species
of beasts to discover a dynamic
day/night cycle like you'd expect and
enough customization to stand out from
the crowd
Caravan stories could be the game for
you here's the thing though originally
this was due to release in July in the
US and Europe but has now slipped to
summer 2019 so we could drop tomorrow or
it could drop in the last week of August
when the date is confirmed I'll bring
you an update
let's look at a game which is only
twenty dollars a third of the price of a
typical game you're looking at rat after
not one but two apocalypses you play as
a character who has been genetically
altered by radiation which allows him to
go around the world and absorb more
radiation hence the title rat which in
turn changes his abilities randomly
causing the player to change their
approach to the game you could have an
arm which becomes a fire blasting weapon
you could suddenly lay an egg and have a
Spider minion to fight beside you
mutations definitely keep the game
interesting rad is also roguelike in
structure if that term causes a little
confusion in this scenario it refers to
the procedural generation of the
expanding world you are in everything is
randomly put together once again leading
back to the importance of replayability
the only persistent area in the game is
your hometown
and should you die in the world say
goodbye to that character they're never
coming back
you'll be given another one a brand new
teenager to roam the world with rad
looks hugely interesting to me will you
give it a try
August 20th if you're into this on ps4
Xbox and PC and finally take a look at
this one remnant of the ashes this one
will likely go under the radar for many
people there is not much in the way of
advertising for this game remnant of the
ashes is a three player cooperative
action shooter
it can be played solo as a duo but if
you want to get the best out of it a
trio we are told is where the game is in
its element after the world is left in
ruins it's up to us to take it back
gunning down abominations and ridding
the world of these undead light
creatures each player chooses a class
with different loadouts the world is
dynamically generated to keep us on our
toes and once again feeds into that
really important word of replayability
one example given to PC gamer was this
you run into an old man out in the world
who seems like a normal merchant at
first but depending on how you interact
with him he could give you a pocket
watch if you have that watch when you
meet his son who is actually a mini boss
things will go very differently than
they would otherwise so this shows our
interactions matter in this gaming world
I'm still struggling to get my head
around what this game actually is so
opinions would be greatly appreciated in
the comments below
remnant of the ashes releases on ps4
Xbox one and PC on August 20th so there
we have it August in a nutshell what
games are you playing this month and
what would you like me to play let me
know and I'll do that for you on a quick
nod to life is strange - which has
episode 4 releasing on August 22nd and
there's a small game called fortnight
you probably haven't heard of it but did
you know on August 1st season 10 drops I
think we're done here
thank you very much for your time what
are you playing this month I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
see you next time
[Music]